[Music]
we live in a distributed Pangea I mean
we were all one continent once and what
is a border a border is like someone
walking into your house with a can of
gas and a gun and setting the can of gas
down and looking at you and saying this
is my house and you're like what me and
my indigenous family have lived here for
centuries like oh this is our house and
colonialism says no no this is my house
and you don't want to go and like
worship our deities and all this things
then like you know you have options and
one is the gun which could be for you or
the other is kick over the can of gas I
can just burn this down and you would
have nothing left and then it would be
much easier for it to be mine and I have
no capital issues rebuilding and after I
destroy it
that's how we created borders what what
kind of a world do we live in where
that's like an extent where that's
acceptable and now I mean that's still
acceptable all over the world today it's
just generally not as public but it's
nuts and do I think that we will live in
a fully borderless world like that's
gonna take a lot of change or a lot of
time and you know we'll see what happens
with the effects of climate change which
could fundamentally have some massive
impacts as far as creating what I would
call a civilized refugee crisis but I
mean the way that we're starting to
think about living in a borderless world
is actually through one of my
technologies and it is called it's
founded by Suzanne Tempelhof and I'm a
partner in the company it's called bit
nation and bit nation is essentially the
idea of Facebook for governance or DIY
government and we start out creating a
borderless society by actually working
on a human rights platform for people
who have been
disenfranchised so we use blockchain
technology to give refugees a global
identity a one-world citizenship and we
also do all of the e identity for the
government of Estonia so we work within
systems of government who are interested
in using these technologies but in a way
that fundamentally empowers every person
on earth to exist to have the right to
live to exist and to be and to be
recognized so that's how we're starting
this world that has the potential to at
least at least for the time being have
more fluid borders and in the future I
personally believe that the idea of
government should be market-based people
should be able to opt in and to opt out
of systems of governance in the ways
that they are able to provide for their
people so governments are actually what
a concept
competing to be better to take care of
their people more than any other
government that is so deeply humanizing
and I think it's absolutely necessary if
we are to live in a world that is going
to have any kind of autonomous
self-governing organization so we're
yeah that's our whole world is creating
new holic rhotic systems of government
and we start by giving it to people who
need it more than anyone because those
people should not be forgotten
there are so many brilliant things and
incredible things that distributed
ledger technology can provide for
generally the benefit of our entire
human race
like allowing people who are financially
disenfranchised to have access to
services that they would have never had
before like owning their own land
titles owning their own identity being
able to create contracts without third
party interference and in that way
there's so much magic I mean giving
people who live in economies where their
currency is so overinflated and that's
just out of their hands and out of their
control if you live in Venezuela for
example and the exchange rate and the
amount of inflation is so high that a
bag of flour cost three hundred and
thirteen dollars that kind of a
technology distributed ledger Bitcoin
the internet of money that's huge for
those people and I think you know the
serious cons of this could be one that a
lot of institutions who are building
distributed ledger technology are
building in a way that doesn't
necessarily expand the way that they're
looking at this technology a lot of
people are building they're spending
like millions of dollars building
massive Excel spreadsheets not actually
blockchains
and I think that's a very current issue
but in the long term if we're living in
a world where all of that information is
transparent or public and you're never
able to delete something that you do and
all of that information is not owned by
the system that is the technology and
you can't mask your identity or have
your own privacy and everything you do
every step you take is is monitored and
held in the hands of a public
organization that's apocalyptically
threatening and I think that we have to
make sure that this technology and
honestly based on the ethic and the
ideology of which the technology is
invented it's it's very it's very
unlikely that it's going to be able to
go in that way because of the impact the
positive benefit that it's actually
going to bring to people around the
world
that's genuine genuinely scary for
everyone because it's not like you can
go in and one person randomly
because they have a position of power
can edit something in or out that's not
how it works so you have to preserve the
integrity of the technology which is
that blockchain technology is borderless
it is voluntary it is decentralized and
it is immutable and in being immutable
it's extremely important that the
technology remains pseudo anonymous
because let's say you're living in an
area where you are under the forces of a
corrupt and violent government and let's
say you are doing something to you know
you are trying to lead a liberation and
if you are cataloging your information
in a way that is going to be forever
capable of being seen and in a way that
your identity is not owned by the
individual but is owned by an
institution that's terrifying
that is a dystopian future and we cannot
live in that kind of a world
so with these kind of a technologies you
have to realize that we're just at the
beginning of what is about to be this
balloon and blossom and this is why it
is so important for people to begin to
practice and to own their own autonomy
in a fundamentally different way there's
not just one blockchain and this is the
beauty of the blockchain ecosystem is
that you have block chains like the
Bitcoin blockchain which fundamentally
is like the most secure it's it's the
original block chain and the Bitcoin
blockchain is particularly interesting
because the creator of the Bitcoin
blockchain who goes under the moniker
Satoshi Nakamoto is invisible and so you
have actually from within the system no
general singular point of authority you
don't have a benevolent dictator in
Bitcoin because the creator
understanding the value system of what
he was doing or she removed themselves
from the project and essentially became
invisible to the internet dropped off
the face of the earth Satoshi Nakamoto
has had one last little bit of
communication in 2011 to tell everyone
that Dorian Nakamoto
who is this innocent Japanese band that
was accused of being Satoshi and all of
a sudden was thrown into the media to
say the Dorian Nakamoto was you know not
actually Satoshi Nakamoto please stop
harassing him people from the press and
so that's actually the beauty of the
Bitcoin blockchain and the way that it
is not only ideologically constructed in
practice but in action from the founder
but the Bitcoin blockchain isn't the
only blockchain in fact there are many
block chains and there will probably be
many more block chains and it's a
healthy robust ecosystem for a lot of
these block chains to have
interoperability for example there is
the etherium block train and etherium is
primarily used for smart contracts and
you essentially have people that are
capable of creating apps like the in the
Apple App Store except that those apps
can have their own independent crowd
sale and can be independently monetized
by the people who use those applications
and who believed in the ideas so
essentially instead of having a big VC
funding round someone can come in and
say I really think that doing a
blockchain based prediction market is is
fascinating and it's something that has
only become possible because of
blockchain technology so instead of
going adventure route I'm actually gonna
open up this idea this technology that I
built on the etherium platform which is
a blockchain to the community and I'm
going to allow the community to fund
this idea with something like ether
which is the currency of aetherium and
in doing that we not only have the money
to build but people also have the
ability to become monetized as they
interact on our platform in our system
and so I think the future for blockchain
technology is fundamentally because you
have opt-in principles it's like would
you if you had the choice would you opt
in to a restricted Internet
No and so I think that generally people
are going to move toward the ideas that
inherently and fundamentally give them
the most opportunity and the most
freedom but in my personal opinion it's
it's healthy to have this robust
ecosystem of ideas where many people can
create and fundamentally in the true
nature of this technology being a
market-based invention people are able
to choose they're able to choose which
blockchain provides the best services
for them what matches with their
ideology how they believe and how they
want to carry out their life and so
fundamentally it's not necessarily I
would like to believe that the wisdom of
the crowds will guide us in the right
direction for this technology because
what is the value of something like this
if it is not for the people
participating in the system
[Music]